A running joke, a conspiracy, a challenge,
a raspberry to authority and (at least formerly)
an exclusive club, the members of the Order
of the Occult Hand are those journalists who
have successfully snuck the meaningless phrase
“occult hand” past their editors and into
published newspaper articles.
How did this all start?
According to two of its founding fathers,
Joseph Flanders and R.C. Smith, in the fall
of 1965, a group of Charlotte News reporters,
while purportedly enjoying a few alcoholic
beverages, began to critique a recent piece
written by their colleague, the aforementioned
Joseph Flanders.
Into a “complicated story of evil-doing,”
Flanders had placed the phrase “It was as
if an occult hand had reached down from above
and moved the players like pawns upon some
giant chessboard.”
One of the contingent supposedly teased, “Now
that is what I call prose.”
From that point on “The Order of the Occult
Hand” was formed and Flanders’ colleagues
became committed to secreting the phrase into
their work.
According to founding father R.C. Smith, “virtually
all succeeded.”
And as they moved on to other papers, word
spread, and the Order grew.
In 1967, Victor McElheny, a reporter with
the rival, Charlotte Observer, who was apparently
aware of the Order, if not a member, moved
to Boston where the phrase became so popular
that eventually it was banned from The Boston
Herald.
One of the Order’s early evangelists was
Jay Sharbutt, who had picked up the “occult
hand” while in Boston and joined the Order
in 1978 (when he put it in an article published
by the Associated Press).
Not long after, he moved to The Los Angeles
Times, and in 1983 Sharbutt told several Times
reporters about it.
These Los Angeles Times reporters were among
the most successful with getting the phrase
into their publication, putting it into stories
in 1983, 1985, 1989 and 1994, as well as eight
times between 1996 and 1998.
In 1999, it was even placed into a story of
President Clinton’s impeachment.
The “occult hand” has also appeared in
The New York Times, The Boston Globe (9 times
between 1987 and 2000) and The Washington
Times (4 times between 1996 and 1998).
At least four of its manifestations in The
Boston Globe came from M.R. “Monty” Montgomery.
As a master of the Order, Monty seamlessly
placed the phrase with sentences like “If
a president of Harvard ever intervenes in
something like a promotion or a course outline,
it is well disguised, the work of an occult
hand.”
So how do we know about this “secret”
society today?
Information about the Order had been published
at various times over the years, including
by former president of the American Journalism
Review and dean of the University of Maryland’s
journalism school, Reese Cleghorn (who had
learned of the Order while working in Boston
in the 1970s).
Cleghorn wrote two columns about it, and as
a result, he received letters from Joseph
Flanders and R.C. Smith detailing the Order’s
origins (as relayed above).
In more recent years, the Order has become
less popular, although the “occult hand”
continues to pop-up occasionally, including
in weather coverage (Mark Lane of the Daytona
Beach News-Journal 2006), entertainment editorials
(Don Kaplan of the New York Daily News 2013),
political stories (Chase Purdy in The Roanoke
Times 2013), and even student sports reporting
(Michael Cheiken for the University of Chicago’s
Chicago Maroon 2014).
On the other hand, many former Order members
have moved on to other challenges.
Pulitzer Prize winner Paul Greenberg, Order
member six times over, wrote in 2006 that
because of the exposé on the topic and “the
lazy types who threw the magic phrase into
their copy so artlessly [that it] . . . gave
the whole conspiracy away,” he was giving
up on the “occult hand,” in lieu of a
new phrase.
With the criteria that it had to be “bad
enough to be spotted by the cognoscenti but
likely to get past the casual copyreader,”
Greenberg and other Order members considered
(and presumably rejected) phrases such as
“like a soft, warm weird breeze blowing
aimlessly through the palms,” and “hanging
over the scene like a shroud.”
They eventually settled on a phrase currently
unknown to the public, and as of 2006, there
were supposedly 11 “certified members”
into the new secret Order.